anytime on cbs
these pacific ocean waters may look
pristine from above
but lurking beneath is an environmental
tragedy that's been unfolding
for generations a toxic dump site that
settled on the ocean floor decades ago
continues to wreak havoc on marine life
to this day
meteorologist and climate specialist
jeff beradelli is back
with more data that toxic chemical is
making its way
higher and higher up the food chain now
it's in marine mammals up and down the
california coast so
we traveled there to see how these
creatures are paying the price
for environmental missteps from a half a
century ago
loud and exceptionally social sea lions
are known for making a scene
but this california sea lion is sick
known affectionately as moon cake she's
being screened at the marine mammal
center which is right near the golden
gate bridge
she's just one of hundreds of struggling
sea lions rescued from california
beaches each year
another indication veterinarians say of
just
how much the ocean is plagued about 25
percent
of the adult and sub adults do have
cancer
and that is an extremely alarming number
as
lead veterinarian dr cara field examines
rescued sea lions for cancer
given the very severely high rate and
how abnormal it is
it's really important that we understand
what is driving this disease in these
animals
and now we may just have an answer a
recently published study
points to high levels of ddt in the
mammal's blubber
before it was banned in 1972 ddt was
used
worldwide as a pesticide the nation's
largest
manufacturer was right on the california
coast
montrose chemical opened up its los
angeles plant in 1947.
by 1970 it was clear something was very
wrong
when a recent report showed a high
presence of ddt in the fish
residents were shocked this polluted
pacific water was coming from
millions of pounds of ddt discharged by
montrose
david valentine a university of
california marine biologist
spent 10 years looking into the
company's past practices
so they dumped them into the storm
drains they dumped them into the
sanitary sewer
in response a 34 square mile area just
off shore
was designated as a superfund cleanup
site
montrose was sued and almost half of the
140 million dollar settlement
was used by noaa to try to restore at
least some
of the contaminated habitat and one of
the goals of the restoration funds and
restoration work
is to enhance fisheries so the
government tasked
jonathan williams a marine biologist
from occidental college
to design a seven acre artificial reef
just off the beach
so by providing healthier habitat right
here
that means that it's less likely ddt is
entering the food chain
that's correct if you have healthier
habitat you're going to have healthier
fish
for several decades scientists and
regulators were focused on the hazardous
toxic superfund site
just about two miles offshore while all
the while an even more shocking
discovery
was waiting to be unearthed about 10
miles offshore
in between here and catalina island
large barrels of ddt waste were being
taken out on a barge and then jettisoned
and dropped to the sea floor
chasing rumors of this second massive
montrose dump site three thousand feet
below
valentine sent a submersible autonomous
robot
down into the abyss lo and behold there
are
likely thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of barrels
of ddt on the ocean bottom and getting
the first pictures back was really the
moment we went
oh wow we're the first people to lay
eyes on this and 60 70 years
but even with this underwater video
there was no response
let alone any course of action i've been
beating the drum on this for 10 years
i've talked to numerous
people within agencies within government
trying to to generate
some interest but last year after
valentine published his findings
interest finally followed 10 years after
your initial research
an article comes out in the fall and
then all of a sudden there's a reaction
to it and there's a big research project
going on right now just offshore that's
exactly right
and i hope it is just the first of many
things that gets done
last month 35 000 acres of ocean floor
was surveyed by scripps institution of
oceanography
the final count of barrels is still
being tallied
but researchers describe their findings
as overwhelming
but this new information is too little
too late
for many of california's sea lion
population
veterinarians had to euthanize 29
mammals last year alone
all because of cancer in the coming
months the plan is for state and federal
agencies to convene
to figure out just how to respond to
these shocking
findings now scripps says the report's
going to be done by the end of the month
and by then we will know just how many
barrels there are
but there could be as many as a half a
million barrels
so then the question becomes what if
anything can be done
to clean up this mess and i think the
moral of the story guys is
what we do now affects generations ahead
our children
grandchildren great grandchildren same
problem with climate change can you
like literally physically go down lift
it up take it out
it seems risky i mean because if you
pick them up they're 3000 feet down
there's a different pressure down there
so this is not going to be easy
if they can even do anything at all in
10 years